obviously Kobe meant a lot to you
um his death is probably the most like
traumatic unexpected I didn't know Kobe
Bryant I'm a basketball fan though you
know and that [ __ ] really [ __ ] me up
um for you man
you know was Kobe always there for you
even through the low times because you
you obviously had a lot of a lot of love
yeah
always
see I'll take a show
[ __ ] um
moves on my being an addict you know
what I'm saying yeah so
when I was playing
like
I never like gambled like heavy um
like that
what else y'all doing I'm out the NBA
yeah
I'm not making
the money I used to make
I [ __ ] pick up a gambling addiction
the worst
how bad was it really bad so
I'm gonna tell you why I got bad really
bad casual
that whole that was that's a straight
line [ __ ]
because
she let you [ __ ] who's you think is
going to be all sweet like that all the
time yeah oh yes the worst I've been
there listening like that's all sweet
all the time remember the first time I
would maybe get into a heavy I was in
I was in Florida at the Hard Rock Me and
My Man leaning free Carlos is dead
I started for like
no [ __ ] like 2500.
I ran it all the way up to like 60k that
night and it was to me it was no better
feeling than going upstairs taking your
money putting it in the safe like gosh
damn
but that's all it takes that's one of
those nights at least it unleash the
same
demon like that cocaine Unleashed to me
man
so make a long story short
I'm in a hole like I can't get myself
out of it
I don't got the money to pay it
um
you know what I mean
that's why I'm like what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna do so
everybody know Kobe was like an extra
Frugal [ __ ] right
I'm like
I think I might have to make the coolest
[ __ ] I'm like I don't know if
I'm gonna
get cursed out
what the [ __ ] you doing LOL
come on
call them
after he cursed me out what the [ __ ]
you're doing hello so you'll just have
your people call my people
so he got you at your Gambling Hall
facts how deep were you in really deep
can you give us the number
north of six figures
yeah
so when you're in like a gambling hole
is that like you're using boogies are
you like no I'm not I'm using my money
to get out I don't want to use no bookie
or
what was your game
Blackjack oh yeah and roulette I see
roulette I love roulette like roulette I
love her that you know what's [ __ ] up
about roulette is you'll [ __ ] get to
a table
and you'll see like you always think
that there's a strategy to roulette but
there isn't now there's ways you could
play to increase your channel
in Vegas at the SLS I play roulette
everywhere I go yeah I like relaying
craps but what I do is I'll bet
um you know how you could bet the
outside the thirds
so I'll bet two of the thirds at the
same time yeah and if one of those hits
I win because they pay two to one you
know so if I put 10 on each one and one
of the two hits I win ten dollars in
profit if I lose I triple up that bet
onto and you keep tripling every time
you lose and then it's it's a strategy
it works but it's also if you get on a
losing streak you're like you could be
[ __ ] asked out unless you're online
yeah I love roulette though well that's
amazing
so you you discover gambling gambling
[ __ ]
gets to the point where you're six
figures in the hole I ain't got nobody
called but Kobe right
and Kobe Saves the Day
the cheapest man I know probably
wow
and like that's not an easy call to make
I don't know like let me call one of the
greatest players of all time I got Pride
one of my closest friends and ask him
for some money did he make you pay it
back
he was a great businessman you know that
yeah
so you had to pay back of course
well I mean
you did pay it back of course nice and
interest no no wow
shout out to Kobe save the day man